yeah welcome to this video what to play
play the filly door I'll try to get to a
filly daughter some modern pretty don't
move order against McShane 90 form from
British Indian Ocean Territory cool all
kinds of funky countries but you can
just to choose one it's not connected in
any way to your internet connection or
something
oh cool he's playing him playing one of
those g4 lines but he had played Bishop
c4 b3 we cool this is possible he as
well yeah I think you're simply nowadays
you're not safe anymore from all kinds
of kinds of nonsense happening I came
she fought
so I can actually take and then maybe
play the Fife and I can't play d5 it's
not completely how thinkable but that's
G 5 then D 5 g 5g takes the force is
even on something to consider
it's not them not idiotic but okay let's
just prepare D 5
hmm would have thought that short castle
combined with deform this sum is a bit
shaky but he's very relaxed about this
it seems
Wow really opening it up I thought he 5
maybe he's got a tactical idea him 25
he's going um
oh no he cannot convert f5 stupid yeah
then then I don't really understand what
he's doing to be honest I am
why Wheaton why we can yourself so much
Knight a5 might be this sort of yeah
escape edge at some point but it just
feels why this very loose if he could
play g4 to g2 back when it's probably am
patrol came I mean again black has got
the two bishops but yeah here just look
to book to d8 would be the next smooth
it's not so easy to play something here
yeah well I can take I can take him a
couple of times but I'm not sure if I
really want to
hmm that's not not so great but I can
grab why not - come on take it
it's um it's it should be okay at least
he can take on a seven but I didn't
didn't feel that rookie eight planning
trying to get read get rid of the rooks
you can play Bishop e6 maybe this would
be six now and now what am i doing now
need to make some room here rupee eight
now it's not great in terms of freedom
of development okay
not sure why it's going to or something
maybe I can not even play a five would
be a five would be helpful and 5h4
probably
I didn't want want him to block it if
possible not again
so that he cannot go rookie one it's
still very equal ish without any doubt
maybe they'll care Kim G father for was
both my idea could be a one idea g5f for
Bishop e6 and then try rook e8 something
but it's probably a as mentioned quite
George anyway I'd be Bishop a4 Bishop h4
maybe Bishop h4 if he allows it it does
allow it but maybe not so terrible but
still yeah but it's not so terrible
a better g5 and therefore this this
might be some substantial progress if I
managed to do it let's let's try that
I want to play h5
and that looks nice it looks nice how to
progress here
maybe Bishop f4
to g3 maybe yeah it's not really a big
threat or anything winning a pawn is not
a big threat him
and maybe Andy - I need to go with the
with the Bishop all around to f1 that
maybe can can take h3 some hope this is
this is very helpful very helpful unless
I'm blundering something which can
always happen of course yeah right
before or something okay
check
now it's it's still probably just a draw
but maybe I've silly his exact he's
going exactly there and I I give it away
I didn't I didn't really look at the
time or I won on time didn't really pay
attention to the clock you know yeah
okay it's it's a strong I thought them I
must I must go here of course try to
attack a three but okay it's it's a draw
it's a draw anyway they probably erupted
him there there is something I've got
the two bishops now in a wide open
position at there should be something
with precise plane now 96 is some
annoyance like this just maybe just back
here here maybe here and something like
this I don't know it's but I would need
to analyse that with a bit more more
time on my hands that there should be
something for black the two bishops are
ours something okay was a bit lucky he
run a ran out of time at the end yes
thanks for watching